bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regardez mission spéciale consacrée ce
soir à la guerre en Ukraine une guerre
au cœur de l'Europe déclenchée par
Vladimir Poutine au petit matin une
guerre totale de haute intensité jusqu'à
Kiev la capitale qui a déjà fait de
nombreuses victimes parmi les civils la
condamnation est unanime c'est un
tournant dans notre histoire a dit le
chef de l'État le G7 l'Europe l'OTAN se
réunissent le Parlement va se réunir
aussi peut-on encore arrêter le maître
du Kremlin jusqu'où cette guerre nous
oblige nous les Européens grands débat
spécial tout de suite avec nos invités
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous cherchez les
spectateurs merci d'être au rendez-vous
bonsoir Jean-Louis bourlange merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
présider la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'Assemblée vous avez passé
l'heure avec nous pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé ce 24
février
2022 l'entrée des chars russes en
Ukraine l'attente la plus grave à la
paix en Europe depuis des décennies vous
nous direz si vous êtes d'accord avec
cette analyse c'est celle d'Emmanuel
Macron bonsoir Nicolas Tenzer merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes philosophe
Russie qui décrypte l'actualité russe
bonsoir Tatiana Jean merci d'être avec
nous grande spécialistes de la Russie
directrice du Centre de recherche sur la
Russie de Livry l'Institut français des
relations internationales sans question
sur la Russie de Poutine bien sûr c'est
votre dernier ouvrage chez thaïlandais
ce soir depuis Washington la député en
marche Valéria forme une scène bonsoir
madame je sais que vous êtes un choc ce
soir vous êtes française née en Ukraine
vous présidez le groupe d'amitié franc -
Ukraine l'Ukraine un peu seul ce soir
vous nous direz ce que vos amis vos
contacts en Ukraine vous disent de ce
qui se passe sur place et puis Benjamin
date directeur Europe de l'Atlantique et
aussi avec nous lui est à Varsovie à la
frontière justement de l'Ukraine et nous
parlera de ce que peuvent faire les
Américains Joe Biden va s'exprimer je
vous donne la parole à tous mais celui
qui nous plante le décor on ne dérange
pas la tradition même si c'est une
émission spéciale c'est Stéphane
blackovski l'ai fait si j'ai bien
compris
[Musique]
Stéphane ce soir
tout se passe exactement comme l'avait
prédit les Américains donc je vous
propose regarder ce que disait Joe Biden
c'était donc le 18 février il y a 6
jours
nous avons des raisons de croire que les
forces russes préparent une attaque de
l'Ukraine dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains jours nous pensons qu'il
vise qui Ève la capitale une ville de
2800000 habitants innocents
voilà c'était le 18 février on est le 22
c'est ce qui s'est passé exactement et
pourtant
même madame Jean elle disait aussi bon
non franchement il a quand même beaucoup
pas perdre madame
[Musique]
à l'époque
pas la biéloris par la frontièreuse par
la frontière russe par la Crimée et puis
surtout il y a eu ses frappes
de missile pour détruire soit des bases
aériennes soit des systèmes de missiles
donc on peut regarder la carte et voir
que effectivement il y a une
concentration de point rouge autour de
Kiev là qui est le au nord du pays donc
sa compréhension exactement à ce que dit
Joe Biden effectivement
pas digéré
c'est justement pour faire appel à ce
registre d'histoire on l'écoute
cher camarades vos pères grand-père et
arrière-grand-père ne se sont pas battus
pour défendre notre patrie pour que les
néo-nazies d'aujourd'hui prennent le
pouvoir en Ukraine vous avez prêté
serment d'allégeance au peuple ukrainien
et non à la jungle anti-populaire qui
vole et harcèle son propre peuple ne
suivez pas ces ordres criminels
donc l'objectif c'est supprimer la
démocratie
[Musique]
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire bon bah
déjà on peut exprimer notre soutien
ukrainien c'est ce qu'a fait le
président
la France se tient au côté de l'Ukraine
mais une question que je voudrais vous
poser est-ce que vous considérez que par
exemple
pas forcément
à ceux qui tenteraient d'interférer avec
nous et plus encore de menacer notre
pays notre peuple doivent savoir que la
réponse de la Russie sera immédiate et
conduira à des conséquences que vous
n'avez encore jamais connu
clair qui se faisaient en Russie doit-on
aller pour tenir tête à Poutine
par Stéphane Jean-Louis bourlange je
voudrais que vous mettiez des mots sur
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui on a
l'impression voilà on est encore un peu
dans la sidération moi personnellement
je ne pensais pas voilà voir ma vie
aujourd'hui au 21e siècle l'invasion
d'un pays d'une démocratie souveraine au
cœur de l'Europe c'est un tournant là ce
qui est en train de s'opérer c'est très
grave ce qui se fait est un tournant
majeur nous avons une nation
ukrainienne qui était indépendante dont
l'indépendance avait été reconnue
notamment par la Fédération de Russie en
94 les garanties avaient été apportées
aux frontières elles ont été
marginalement mais réellement violé avec
l'annexion de la Crimée mais on avait
une situation et là nous nous trouvons
en face d'une agression caractérisée
totalement injustifiée elle est
justifications sont démontes
l'accusation de génocide la lutte contre
les nazis mais je vous rappelle
simplement que les Allemands quand ils
sont entrés en Pologne en 39 prétendait
réagir à une agression polonaise donc on
est c'est vraiment du bidon de la
propagande bidon comme on en a jamais vu
cela dit ce que je voudrais dire c'est
donne-moi pas du tout étonné je fais
partie comme Monsieur denzer comme comme
vous de l'école réaliste et quand on
voit ce qui a été annoncé par le
président Poutine le 13 juillet confirmé
en novembre confirmer en décembre les
instruments diplomatiques qu'il a mis en
circulation on est effectivement en
présence d'une action très très forte
très déterminée à l'ampleur de
l'offensive sur l'ensemble du territoire
de 4 dernières semaines c'est que si
Poutine ne fais rien il perdait la face
parce que s'il faisait rien les
gesticulations qu'elle y s'était livrées
jusqu'à présent conduisait à
ressusciter le temps sortie de sa mort
cérébrale à intégrer à le temps
potentiellement la Suède et la Finlande
a reconstitué une nation
ukrainienne
indépendante et hostile à l'égard de la
Russie et à réintégrer les États-Unis
qui n'avaient Dieu jusqu'à ce dernier
mois que pour le Pacifique dans
l'Atlantique donc c'était un échec donc
il fallait qu'il fasse quelque chose
lundi il a fait quelque chose il a pris
le contrôle des républiques de l'Est moi
j'ai à ce moment-là penser je l'ai écrit
d'ailleurs que ça ne lui suffisait pas
parce que en prenant ce contrôle il se
privait
d'un instrument important qui était les
accords de Minsk qui lui permettait en
fait d'avoir un pied dans la conduite
des affaires
ukrainiennes est-ce qu'il aurait pu
vouloir si tu l'espèce de fédération à
la belge dans lequel c'est en Belgique
et wallon et les flamants ne peuvent
rien faire les uns sans les autres donc
il aurait pu imposer un orque quand il
annexé les républiques il s'interdisait
ça
pouvait-il à ce moment-là dans son
esprit laisser partir le reste de
l'Ukraine vers l'ouest je ne le croyais
pas et j'ai donc pensé que il y aurait
forcément sous une forme ou sous une
autre une intervention visant l'Ukraine
et c'est ce que nous avons eu donc je
suis absolument atterré mais je ne suis
pas surpris
la capitale ukrainienne on se demande
même si la ville ne sera pas prise dès
ce soir la capitale Nicolas
le 14 ans voire plus que l'alerte sur ce
régime comme d'autres je ne suis pas le
seul peut-être minoritaire en France
quand même dès 2008
l'affaire Georgienne 20 % du territoire
géorgien sont toujours des facto les
République fantôche d'apkasi et de cité
du Sud
occupé par la Russie
2014 avec déjà l'occupation qui l'a
cessé depuis ce moment-là de une partie
des oblast pour des régions
politiques ici dans d'autres pays il y a
eu un aveuglement total absolument des
dirigeants des dirigeants je dirais
parfois français européen américain
aussi je veux dire personne quasiment à
part certains amis responsables
d'experts ont alerté y compris je peux
le dire je veux pas révéler des choses
en détail mais y compris plusieurs fois
Emmanuel Macron je lui ai dit clairement
que toute tentative de discussion
avec Vladimir Poutine était Vennes
étaient voué
russe n'a fait que se renforcer en terme
de force numérique si j'ose dire mais
aussi en terme de capacité technologique
c'est comme quand vous avez une maladie
si vous prenez un maladie un peu trop
tard mais le patient risque d'être
nous avons dans cette guerre
ce n'est pas la guerre de l'Ukraine
uniquement même si l'Ukraine a fait
depuis 8 ans la guerre par procuration
c'est notre guerre c'est la guerre de
l'Europe c'est la guerre de la France
nous sommes en guerre je dis bien nous
sommes pas uniquement l'Ukraine et nous
avons une responsabilité immense alors
c'est pas le moment maintenant
ne faut pas négocier avec la Russie de
Poutine parce que vous savez il y a ce
régime je crois qu'il faut connaître la
ce n'est pas la Russie qui est en cause
et il faut bien distinguer la Russie et
les ruches le peuple russe du régime
mais le régime je dirais on a
suffisamment d'alerte il y a des
centaines de livres des milliers
d'articles qui ont été écrits qui
décrivent la nature de ce régime et on a
été dans une sorte de mouvement de folie
absolue
voilà le diagnostic est assez est assez
dur et assez sévère que vos Poutine
exactement avec cette attaque massive
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il veut annexer le
crâne tout entière est-ce qu'on peut le
dire ce soir tout d'abord je vais
répondre à un point parce que en effet
j'avais dit que la Russie avait trop à
perdre du Nord opération de l'envergure
et cetera et je pense continu à penser
qu'elle a trop pas perdre qu'à long
terme en vérité les conséquences se sont
absolument désastreuses non seulement
pour l'Ukraine mais aussi pour la Russie
il a une autre rationalité
à lui il sait riche en défenseur de la
sécurité de la Russie du peuple russe il
s'inscrit dans l'histoire longue de la
Russie on est même plus à discuter de
les rugissement de l'OTAN qui a pu fâché
Vladimir Poutine il est en polémique
virtuel avec Lénine et les bolcheviks
sur la création de l'Ukraine donc on
veut recomposer quoi tout l'espace de
sécurité européen ou c'est simplement
une volonté de puissance de la grande
réussite zariste on peut comprendre sa
rationalité comment comment l'expliquer
cristallise toutes les frustrations et
les craintes de Vladimir Poutine c'est
un pays qui depuis 2004 depuis la
Révolution orange le défi avec ses
révolutions sociales avec son
orientation euro Atlantique et qui
désormais inscrite dans la Constitution
ukrainienne il voit le rapprochement
avec le temps sans adhésion officiel
avec les armes qui
concrètement être nazi etc c'est dans la
tête des gens donc qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire exactement moi c'est extrêmement
de personnes et de personnalités
ukrainiennes qui étaient des
personnalités à liquider
je veux dire c'est quand même ça la
réalité ce que Poutine a exprimé tout le
monde le savait depuis un certain temps
c'est qu'il déni le droit à l'Ukraine
voir aux Ukrainiens à l'existence de
même pour le Belarus d'ailleurs c'est
pas que l'Ukraine c'est quand même ça la
réalité c'est-à-dire qu'il veut rayer ce
pays de la carte une certaine manière
vitrifiant nucléairement c'est pas le
sujet mais on le rattachant en disant
finalement l'Ukraine c'est nous nous
reconstituons une forme de grande Russie
mais derrière tout cela dernier point il
y a aussi une volonté idéologique que tu
as une agent d'ailleurs à évoqué sur la
situation Russie qui est une volonté de
destruction il place la Russie sur le
signe de l'absence de futur il a
sacrifié totalement l'économie du ce
pays le bien-être social regarder la
crise de la covid 19 avec ce bilan
absolument monstrueux en Russie et tu as
des hôpitaux des écoles c'est un
sacrifice terrible il a fait le malheur
de son peuple et je crois que ça aussi
il faut le dire pas longtemps
ils sont vraiment c'est une infime
minorités
qui pourrait avoir lieu à Moscou seront
réprimés on l'a pris aujourd'hui
mais avec peu de personnes finalement
dans ma ville natale et qui était
rainburg et je lui en échange très vif
ce matin je l'avais dit sur Twitter avec
ma famille et j'ai décidé de constater
le soutien apporté à la politique de
Vladimir Poutine toute la rancune en
fait je me suis rendu compte de l'impact
de la propagande qui se déverse sur les
russes depuis minimum 2014 sur les nazis
contre l'attaque et estime que il n'y
avait pas d'autre choix pour Vladimir
Poutine que de faire ce qu'il est en
train de faire je voudrais qu'on regarde
un petit peu maintenant en images ce qui
se passe actuellement en Ukraine et aux
alentours de qui a fait
je le disais à la fois terrestre et
aérienne sur l'ensemble du territoire 11
aéroports ont été détruits des combats
au sol aux alentours de Kiev près de
Tchernobyl également et les premières
images des victimes civiles c'est un
récit signé par Marco poli
[Musique]
des bombardements ce matin les
Ukrainiens se sont réveillés dans un
pays en guerre partout depuis sans
explosion retentissent ni pro Poltava ou
encore Kiev à l'ouest du pays c'est un
missile qui s'est abattu sur un aéroport
international les civils étaient à
quelques mètres seulement
officiellement la Russie vise des cibles
militaires ukrainiennes mais des
quartiers résidentiels ont été touchés
comme ici à carquif ce bâtiment n'a pas
résisté au souffle de l'impact sur les
réseaux sociaux le président
ukrainien appelle ses concitoyens ne pas
paniquer
nous imposons la loi martiale dans
toutes les régions de notre état les
États-Unis ont déjà commencé à préparer
le soutien international nous avons
besoin que vous restiez calme
aujourd'hui si possible restez chez vous
mais pour beaucoup la peur placer le
relatif calme de ces dernières semaines
à Mario Paul dans le sud du pays ses
habitants sont obligés d'évacuer
depuis ce matin dans les grandes villes
du pays où à Kiev les sirènes d'urgence
résonnent dans la capitale des milliers
d'habitants tente de fuir en voiture
provoquant de gigantesques
embouteillages les gares les trains
aussi sont pris d'assaut un exode massif
pour s'éloigner de la menace mais
certains hésitent encore à partir on va
essayer de sauver nos vies
l'espoir c'est le métro car c'est un
abri où nous serons en sécurité
le métro de Kiev un abri contre les
bombardements parmi ceux qui ont fait le
choix de rester en Ukraine beaucoup se
massent devant les distributeurs de
banque ou les magasins d'alimentation
pour faire le plein de denrées
je préfère faire des provisions dans
l'offensive russe plusieurs dizaines de
personnes ont déjà été tué selon la
président ukrainienne des militaires
surtout mais aussi des civils
Valeria forme une scène merci d'être
avec nous et merci beaucoup d'avoir
patienté député en marche né en Ukraine
je le disais vous présidez le groupe
d'amitié
France-Ukraine vous les avez vu
évidemment toutes ces images les
explosions l'exode des Ukrainiens toute
la journée qu'est-ce que vous ressentez
ce soir et que craignez-vous le plus
ce sont des images de fin du monde et
c'est très difficile de voir ça pour 21e
siècle
en Europe sur le continent européen
au-delà de l'attachement que je peux
avoir à ce pays de par mes racines
c'est inadmissible de voir autant de
violence
dans un pays qui est censé être
souverain et libre et démocratique donc
je suis atterré je suis
déçu du fait que
les
Russes qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
chars ou qui tiennent les armes ce sont
des frères et des cousins des Ukrainiens
sur lesquels ils tirent et je trouve
cette aberration
dramatique qu'on en soit arrivé là
malgré tout ce qui avait été mis en
œuvre du point de vue diplomatique de
point de vue de négociation
je pense qu'il est plus utile de revenir
sur les parce que les conséquences sont
alors justement Vladimir Poutine a pris
une décision et il a pris malgré tout ce
qui avait été mis en œuvre il a pris la
décision de d'envoyer les armes le pire
donc on a l'impression que l'armée
ukrainienne est dépassée forcément elle
est bien moins puissante que que l'armée
russe l'Ukraine est seul trop seul
aujourd'hui
elle est seule de fête elle ne fait pas
partie de l'OTAN elle elle est isolée du
fait que il est difficile pour les
occidentaux de rentrer en guerre contre
la Russie s'il y a une riposte
occidentale il me semble se
déclencherait une troisième guerre
mondiale donc c'est pas anodin comme
prise de décision maintenant j'appelle à
l'ensemble des dirigeants et mais
évidemment le président de la République
a fournir les moyens
tous les moyens utiles à l'armée
ukrainienne et à la population civile
ukrainienne pour résister sans rentrer
en guerre au sol on peut contribuer par
des aides armement tactiques pour
accompagner les yeux
c'est notre guerre c'est notre guerre à
nous les Européens ça n'est pas la
guerre de Vladimir Poutine en Ukraine
c'est regarde nous les Français
également vous pensez qu'un renfort
militaire suffit vraiment
on est évidemment en responsabilité
parce que la France a fait partie du
format Normandie depuis 2014 évidemment
on est tous responsable de ce qui se
passe sur le continent européen
maintenant est-ce que on est prêt à
déclencher une guerre entre l'Occident
et la Russie une guerre qui qui mettrait
en position les pays détenant l'arme
nucléaire est-ce qu'on est capable de
faire ça aujourd'hui je dis pas qu'il
faut abandonner les Ukrainiens
absolument pas bien au contraire il faut
leur apporter tout le soutien et les
sanctions seuls ne suffiront pas depuis
2014 elles ont pas dissuadé Vladimir
Poutine mais on est clairement face à un
personnage qui a perdu toute notion du
réel et de sens commun qui a pris des
décisions
létales à l'égard rien qui tient un
discours tout à fait incohérent lundi
soir il a quand même dit dans la même
phrase que des Ukrainiens étaient
incapable de maintenir une industrie
mais qu'à la fois ils étaient capables
d'avoir une arme à nucléaire demain et
ce qui m'a choqué et ce qui a présager
effectivement l'attaque même si je
voulais pas y croire c'est quand il
avait dit qu'il
traduirait en justice les responsables
des morts de la révolution de Maiden de
2014 ça présager la prise de pouvoir à
Kiev pour pouvoir tenir un similacre de
justice avec les listings
personne n'arrive à prendre au mot si
j'ose dire Vladimir Poutine il y a
toujours de la sidération ce soir merci
beaucoup Valérie à formulcian de
Washington on va tout de suite partir à
Varsovie avec Benjamin Haddad et je vous
redonne la parole tout de suite c'est
promis en plateau Benjamin date merci
d'avoir patienter également vous diriger
le Département Europe de l'Atlantique 4
d'ailleurs à Varsovie c'est intéressant
première question comment ça se passe ce
soir pays frontalier avec avec l'Ukraine
pays de l'OTAN est-ce que l'inquiétude
est là
l'inquiétude est là et vous savez les
Polonais comme d'autres partenaires
d'Europe centrale et orientale comme les
États baltes mettre en garde le reste de
l'Europe et les États-Unis depuis des
années déjà devant le révisionnisme de
Vladimir Poutine devant ce type de
menace il savent ce que c'est ils ont
été pendant des décennies sous
l'oppression de l'Union soviétique au
sein du pacte de Varsovie on recouvrait
leur souveraineté grâce à l'Union
européenne et à l'OTAN et donc
aujourd'hui on voit beaucoup
d'inquiétudes beaucoup de solidarité
aussi avec ce que vivent les ukrainiens
et une grande manifestation aujourd'hui
dans Vars l'ambassade de Russie par
exemple
doit s'exprimer ce soir jusqu'à présent
tout le monde a compris qu'elle était
répète qu'ils iront jusqu'au bout
sanction ou pas alors il dit ça en
public même si on se rappelle quand même
qu'en 2014-2015 en privé il se plaignait
souvent des sanctions et que les
sanctions plus effectivement le coup
humain et les cercueils qui venaient du
Dombas après l'agression russe déjà en
2014 avait conduit un peu à freiner la
Russie a mener aux accords de cesser le
feu de donc effectivement il faut faire
des sanctions faire des sanctions
massives beaucoup plus
puissantes que celle qu'on a fait
jusqu'ici qui frappe à la fois
l'intégration de la Russie dans le
système financier mondial donc
effectivement poser la question du
système de paiement Swift mais je crois
que le plus important c'est aussi de
frapper les dirigeants de la Russie que
ce soit Vladimir Poutine soit entourage
les oligarques de ce régime qui cachent
beaucoup d'avoir ou des villas
d'ailleurs on le sait en
Occident là aussi est-ce que ce sera
suffisant il nous répète que non il faut
être lucide aussi sur les moyens dont on
mais je crois que c'est très important
et c'est très important aussi de révéler
de d'essayer de le faire au public russe
ce qu'on sait de la corruption
aujourd'hui de ce régime le FBI et
d'autres travail depuis des années à
essayer de voir un peu les l'opacité là
où les avoir de l'élite dirigeantes
russe et caché on sait que c'est un
régime cleptocratique donc je crois que
le révélo grand jour sera très important
mais au-delà de ça puisqu'on l'a dit
c'est vrai que c'est une c'est une
guerre en Europe c'est l'affaire de
l'Europe en 2014 le mouvement de baydan
à Kiev que Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui
il veut punir c'était un mouvement pro
européen tout ça n'avait rien
des prétextes qui est utilisé
aujourd'hui par Vladimir Poutine et donc
c'est important pour nous de soutenir
les Ukrainiens au lieu de la punition
contre le régime de Vladimir Poutine les
souvenirs par de l'aide économique des
souvenirs par de l'aide militaire les
autres intervenants l'ont déjà dit donc
je fais que le répéter c'est aussi notre
guerre c'est la guerre de l'Europe c'est
un vrai tournant dans l'histoire de
notre continent il faut qu'on soit à la
hauteur alors justement merci beaucoup
Benjamin Haddad la question des
sanctions elle est centrale c'est aussi
notre guerre vous êtes d'accord avec
cette expression là
en fait tout est parti de sa volonté de
rejoindre l'Union européenne le temps de
partager les valeurs démocratiques et
cetera c'est depuis 2014 qu'il nous
disent on est on nous défendons vos
valeurs vos valeurs européennes venez
nous aider le président de la République
parce que là on a pas encore le détail
mais on comprend qu'elles vont être plus
dures d'ailleurs le chef de l'État qui a
montré pour la première fois le PC
Jupiter vous savez c'est ce bunker qui
se trouve dans les sous-sols de de
l'Élysée voyez les images écouter le
président de la République justement sur
les sanctions contre la Russie
les sanctions portées à la Russie seront
à la hauteur de l'agression dont elle se
rend coupable sur le plan militaire et
économique autant que dans le domaine de
l'énergie nous serons sans faiblesse
nous appuierons l'Ukraine sans hésiter
et nous prendrons toutes nos
responsabilités pour protéger la
souveraineté et la sécurité de nos
alliés européens
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire très très
concrètement ces sanctions-là sans
faiblesse elle recouvre quoi et est-ce
que ça peut suffire j'attends vraiment
avec impatience qu'on dévoile le détail
des sanctions qui seront mises en place
après cette acte d'agression jusqu'à
présent on parlait de la coupure de
Swift comme la mesure la plus forte à
partir de la Russie c'est déjà préparé à
cela en réduisant la part du dollar dans
ses réserves de change en mettant en
place un système de paiement de
transfert de paiement bancaire à
l'intérieur du pays auquel quelques
autres pays ont commencé à se joindre la
grande question qu'elle sera l'attitude
de la Chine pour aider la Russie la
première réaction de la Chine était
plutôt
comme la Chine n'a pas reconnu
l'annexion de la Crimée donc
officiellement c'est une sorte de
neutralité on accuse pas la Russie mais
on la soutient pas non plus verbalement
mais la grande question Quels sont les
actes concrets derrière pour aider
financièrement ou économiquement la
Russie en cas de de sanction européenne
la Chine n'a quand même pas intérêt à se
fâcher avec l'Occident ou avec l'Union
européenne ou elle a beaucoup d'intérêt
économique à cause de la Russie être
entraîné en fait par la Russie dans une
guerre qui n'est pas la sienne j'espère
que le la Chine ne manquera pas
d'intelligence pour y résister bonsoir
Guy Tessier merci d'être là vous êtes
député les républicains membres de la
commission des affaires étrangères
ancien président de la Commission de la
Défense je reviens vers vous dans un
instant mais je vous sens impatient de
prendre la parole Jean-Louis
de l'arrêter est-ce capable de renverser
le rapport de force ou pas sans envoyer
au fond une force militaire claire de
l'auto côté des Ukrainiens
précis contrairement à ce que dit
Monsieur Poutine qui fait semblant de
croire qu'on est qu'il a été menacé par
le temps nous avons fait un choix très
précis dans les années
en 2008 en vérité à Bucarest qui était
de dire que nous comprenions qu'il y
avait entre l'Ukraine et la Russie une
relation très étroite qui a été rappelé
tout à l'heure moi d'ailleurs j'ai un
filleul qui est
Ukraine au russe et j'ai pu mesurer à
travers lui tout tout les trois tests
des liens les liens historiques nous
étions nous avons reconnu ce que disait
Poutine et dont il ne tient aucun compte
aujourd'hui à savoir que
faire rentrer l'Ukraine dans le temps
était quelque chose qui aurait été
une provocation à l'égard de la Russie
compte tenu des liens historiques
profond entre la Russie et l'Ukraine car
l'Ukraine n'était pas dans la même
situation il faut bien comprendre ça
candidature
ces états-là avaient été asservie
l'Ukraine faisait partie de l'URSS et la
dissolution de l'URSS c'est fait par
consentement mutuel donc nous n'avions
nous avons été prudents et nous avons
été contrairement à ce qui est dit par
Poutine qui fait semblant de croire
qu'il y avait une menace ce qui est
dingue l'idée que l'Union européenne
puisse menacer qui que ce soit c'était
lasse complètement faux et l'idée que
les États-Unis aient été une menace
alors que depuis des années à travers
trois présidents leur et se désengager
au maximum de de l'Europe pour se
concentrer sur le Pacifique ce qu'on
appelle pivot était dingue donc on a eu
cette attitude bon c'est c'est
compatible ce que ce que montre Poutine
aujourd'hui et c'est là où c'est une
faiblesse énorme je pense que Tatiana
sera d'accord avec cette analyse enfin
je la sollicite ce n'est pas d'accord
elle le dira mais je
ce qui montre c'est le démenti total de
son propre discours parce que son
discours c'est de dire que l'Ukraine
fait partie la Russie historique est-ce
que vous croyez qu'il est normal quand
on fait partie d'un pays du même pays de
le bombarder de le détruire de réduire
sa population c'est le démenti et il est
en train de construire c'est pour ça que
je crois qu'à court terme pour répondre
à vos questions nous sommes extrêmement
démunis pour une raison simple
monsieur qui est l'ancien président de
défense nationale de l'union de la du
Parlement de l'Assemblée nationale qui
connaît ces choses on ne gagne pas une
guerre qu'on improvise on ne rentre pas
dans une guerre sans l'avoir préparée et
ce serait effectivement prendre le
risque d'une extension du conflit qui
serait démesuré mais de la part de
Poutine créer cette relation
hostile violente agressive à l'égard de
l'Ukraine c'est créer les bases d'une
rupture entre lui et l'Ukraine durable
et je crois aussi comme peut-être vous
le pensez je ne sais pas je vous
sollicite
qui évidemment est très sensible à la
gloire c'est un pays qui est très
patriotes je pense que fondamentalement
la rupture entre les Russes et les
Ukrainiens n'est pas du goût du peuple
russe donc je crois qu'à terme le choix
coûte de Poutine c'est un choix
erroné et suicidaire mais le terme c'est
pas pour aujourd'hui et cela nous allons
vivre des moments difficiles
et en fait pour aller à même un peu plus
loin
encore plus forte il dit que les russes
et ukrainiens c'est le même peuple mais
le peuple divisé donc si on suit sa
logique il est en train de bombarder une
partie de son propre absolument
derrière laquelle il y a la menace au
tanyenne et occidentale qui se profile
et il s'est trouvé une guerre en fait
il y a 2 jours c'était ces deux
républiques que veulent venir Poutine
avait déclaré comme indépendante et
reconnue 2 jours après il est partout
partout sur le territoire
ukrainien avec des bombardements aériens
avec une présence au sol on dit démunis
on dit schizophrène presque irrationnel
quels sont nos leviers de pression
qu'est-ce que on va faire nous les
Européens face à ce qui se passe est-ce
que cette sanction économique seront
suffisantes ou est-ce qu'il faut
maintenant essayer de trouver les moyens
du temps de le bras ou plus même
la première des choses d'abord c'est
pour répondre à mon collègue et
président puisqu'il est aujourd'hui mon
Président dans la dans le cadre de la
commission des affaires étrangères
Machiavel avait une formule qui disait
on fait la guerre quand on veut et on
arrête quand on peut et donc je veux
dire que Poutine a fait la guerre quand
il a voulu c'est ça la morale de
l'histoire c'est-à-dire qu'il a préparé
ça de très longue date qu'il a amusé les
Européens
je disais il a monté ce qu'on appelle
chez les Russes en combinate à l'égard
de l'Europe il nous a trompé et nous
avec une grande cécité nous sommes
tombés dans le panneau en considérant
que finalement
le gouvernement de cette Russie pouvait
être en compatibilité avec les grands
principes qui régissent l'Europe la
démocratie et l'oxygène
je m'étais rendu en Lettonie et j'avais
été visiblement impressionné par la peur
que les laitons avaient de voir les
Russes revenir
c'était présente tout le temps ils ont
parlé tout le temps déjà et donc
aujourd'hui ça y est ils sont de retour
je crois très franchement que l'Europe
porte dans cette affaire une énorme
responsabilité parce que nous nous
sommes quelque part laissés vassaliser
par l'OTAN car finalement à une époque
Chirac j'étais président de la
commission m'a demandé pour faire la
tournée des capitales européennes
justement pour parler de l'Europe de la
défense et je trouvais un accueil plus
que tiède dans un certain nombre de pays
où on nous disait non non
on veut le bouclier de l'OTAN veut
rentrer dans l'Europe et en vélo temps
voilà et donc ça voulait dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'elle a quasiment un certain
nombre de pays ne souhaitait pas faire
l'effort de la dépense qu'il est
concerné pour avoir des défenses
appropriées
un ours
soviétique ou russe après qui était
toujours aussi agressif et donc nous
nous sommes à moindry nous nous sommes
ramollis et nous sommes aujourd'hui plus
capable en tout cas d'apporter nous les
Européens une riposte militaire digne de
ce nom donc qu'est-ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui les seules choses qui nous
reste aujourd'hui mais il me semble
tristement que c'est déjà trop tard tant
l'offensive russe va vite que il nous
reste plus qu'à un soutien indéfectible
et unanime de l'Europe à la fois comme
l'a dit le président de la République
humanitaire
sanitaire et militaire mais en ce qui
concerne les militaires je ne trahis pas
de secret
il y a aujourd'hui dans les dossiers
d'état-major français la création de ce
qu'on appelle un GTI à sa mère un
groupement militaire qui serait placé
sous commandement français qui devrait
prendre sa place il y a déjà des
éléments précurseurs qui sont partis en
Roumanie mais c'est une posture nous ne
rentrerons pas en guerre en Ukraine
aux frontières
de français et sera sous commandement
français mais avec sans doute d'autres
Européens de nos côtés on continue cette
discussion
mais justement je voudrais vous
solliciter maintenant comme
parlementaire on sent bien qu'on est à
un moment historique c'est aussi un
enjeu démocratique et des normales que
la représentation nationale soit
associée au plus près aux décisions du
politique ce matin les parlementaires ce
sont évidemment émus on réagit à cette
déclaration de guerre de Vladimir
Poutine vous allez le voir c'était dans
l'hémicycle un débat aura lieu
d'ailleurs sans vote mardi prochain tout
comme un message du président Macron
demain à l'Assemblée Stéphanie des
pierres
9h les députés sont réunis pour discuter
de la situation sanitaire mais la Russie
vient d'attaquer l'Ukraine
Frédéric petit est député des Français
de robe centrale il vit en Pologne je
suis non seulement habitant ces régions
j'ai eu quelques coups de fil cette nuit
de ma fille
de Vladimir Poutine son discours et tu
ne déclaration de guerre culturelle
revenir à nous sommes tous russe cette
terre est russe donc je suis le patron
ça ça annonce pour tout le monde le
contraire de ce que nous faisons en
Europe où nous avons 24 langues où nous
acceptons de ne pas être d'accord ou
nous acceptons de ne pas d'être ennemis
héréditaire et de travailler ensemble
à l'unisson majorité et opposition
condamne l'intervention russe la guerre
a éclaté en Europe la guerre a éclaté en
Europe le président Poutine a décidé
d'envahir un pays qui est un pays ami le
terme d'invasion n'est pas trop fort
nous sommes dans une situation pour ma
génération pour de nombreuses
générations qui n'ont jamais connu la
guerre sur le sol européen dans une
entrée dans une phase extrêmement
dangereuse la guerre est aux portes de
l'Europe le message de la France est
clair nous condamnons fermement le
président
internationaux évidemment il est
important que nous puissions ici dans le
cœur de la démocratie que l'Assemblée
nationale le dénoncer de la façon la
plus ferme il s'agit d'un rap d'un
retour au rapport de force brutal niant
tous les principes de droit
international et d'un tangibilité des
frontières que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter tous les groupes d'opposition
ont réclamé un débat devant le Parlement
sur la guerre en Ukraine le gouvernement
a ils m'ont dit oui il aura lieu mardi
au Palais Bourbon et dès demain à 14h30
les députés seront dans l'hémicycle pour
écouter un message d'Emmanuel Macron qui
sera lu simultanément à l'Assemblée et
au Sénat un message du président de la
République au députés c'est très rare
c'est une pratique constitutionnelle
établie c'est effectivement très rare et
ça marque simplement que le président
reconnais ce que nous reconnaissons tous
c'est-à-dire l'extrême gravité la
solennité de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en Europe qui est une rupture
fondamentale par rapport à des années de
vie tranquille et sans doute abusivement
tranquille moi ce que ce que je suis
assez d'accord avec ce qu'a dit chier à
l'instant sauf que je crois qu'on ne
peut pas à la fois reprocher aux
Français et aux Européens d'une façon
générale
arrêter
insuffisamment ouvert sur vis-à-vis de
Monsieur Poutine et d'avoir été en même
temps
d'avoir été trop ouvert
en même temps était lié à le temps je
crois que beaucoup de gens étaient
conscient moi j'appartiens à ses cercles
le cercle commentaire par exemple la
revue de Jean-Claude Casanova où nous
sommes très très attentifs à la menace
russe depuis très longtemps et nous
n'avons été sans aucune illusion et tous
les les contacts que j'ai eu avec les
dirigeants français les diplomates les
militaires les gens de l'Élysée m'ont
montré que il y avait aucune illusion il
y a eu des tentatives de savoir si on
pouvait faire quelque chose avec
Monsieur Poutine parce que c'est
l'intérêt fondamental des Russes
l'intérêt fondamental des Russes c'est
de se rapprocher de l'Union européenne
géopol bon ils sont menacés par les
Chinois géopolitiquement ils sont
opposés au Turcs
de Poutine et ces temps-là qu'elle est
très dure pour nous et qu'elle nous met
en cause directement à travers l'Ukraine
c'est le refus des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres le refus de la démocratie
représentative le refus du pluralisme le
refus de l'État droit le refus d'une
économie ouverte et ça c'est ça qui a
Dominique c'est pas le temps c'est pas
les les tribulations autour de l'attente
car Poutine savait très bien que nous
n'étions pas que l'Ukraine n'allait pas
rentrer dans le temps parce que nous
voulions le ménager
c'est-à-dire une révolte démocratique
c'est le partenariat avec l'Union
européenne et c'est l'idée donc comme je
le disais tout à l'heure que l'Ukraine
allait plutôt basculer vers un modèle
proche de celui de la Pologne de la
tchécos de la Tchéquie ou de la Hongrie
plutôt que de la Biélorussie et ça il ne
pouvait pas le tolérer alors moi je
crois qu'il y a eu aucune naïveté que
nous avons eu le souci de ne pas
provoquer de ne pas provoquer Poutine en
faisant rentrer l'Ukraine qui était un
pays qui était très proche de la Russie
dans le temps nous avons essayé de
construire quelque chose qui était un
concept très juste qui était les
Européens qui ont pas toujours à
Bruxelles a pas toujours des idées très
intelligentes mais là on en avait qu'une
qui était de de passer de voisinage
comme un
Ukraine c'est une marche ça veut dire
marche ça veut dire frontière c'est un
pays ambivalent tourné vers la Russie
tourner vers l'autre et on voulait en
faire un pays du voisinage commun un
trait d'union c'est ce projet qu'on a
voulu et Poutine
la récusé mais je dis je maintiens et
c'est pour ça non pas été dans
l'illusion que ce projet de Poutine est
idiot qu'il est historiquement ça va pas
le conduire à là où il veut il organise
une opposition fondamentale des
Ukrainiens contre lui et très
franchement il ne donne pas satisfaction
aux attentes fondamentales du peuple
russe donc je crois que son avenir sera
plus compliqué que l'on imagine mais à
court terme à court terme c'est
difficile
on parle beaucoup de la question de
l'OTAN l'Ukraine n'est pas dans le temps
donc nous autant
Occident européen nous pouvons pas c'est
la ligne officielle
défendre ce pays militairement au sol ou
par voie aérienne est-ce que c'est la
vraie raison est-ce qu'au fond c'est pas
parce que Poutine alarme nucléaire dont
il a d'ailleurs déjà
brandi la menace que ça n'est pas
envisageable
oui et non parce que non nous aussi nous
avons l'arme nucléaire donc je pense que
vous savez on a l'habitude de dire que
l'arme nucléaire
puisse l'utiliser que je vous dérange ce
sur quoi je dois y revenir si vous me le
permettez
[Musique]
sur quoi vient de parler mon collègue
branlange
quand même quand on reprend le recul et
quand s'aperçoit que dans les années 90
lorsque les Soviétiques à l'époque
acceptent le regroupement ce qui n'était
pas rien des deux Allemagne et qu'ils
acceptent de même suite qu'elle rentre
dans l'OTAN et avec un des contreparties
à ça et là alors même si l'Union
soviétique était chancelante
à ce moment-là la contrepartie c'était
précisément que les autres pays n'entre
pas dans l'OTAN et qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé la conférence de Madrid
sont entrés dans l'OTAN heureusement et
donc bien sûr pour eux et pour nous
d'ailleurs mais c'était une à contresens
de l'accord de Madrid et de la corde 90
de Berlin donc si on peut pas
trop trop l'histoire
tordu le bras avec cœur
qui qui est ton Skype avec toi
moi je aujourd'hui on parle de sanction
Poutine a déjà répondu d'abord ils ont
dit qu'il s'en foutait des sanctions
est-ce que je crois
que nous encore une fois les Occidentaux
habitués à notre confort et tout on
imagine pas la résilience du peuple
russe même si ce pays a évolué même si
aujourd'hui à Moscou il y avait des
manifestations
les siennes seront terribles
nos échanges qu'est-ce que vous avez
envie au fait de dire à la fois comme je
sais que vous êtes française qu'on doit
choisir la nationalité entre l'Ukraine
et la France des Français en Ukraine à
vos collègues députés ce soir
vraiment de la situation et la proximité
du conflit armé et de l'Ukraine on en
parle pas beaucoup de lucrètes en France
d'habitude et on a vraiment besoin de
se rendre à l'évidence à quel point ces
menaçants pour nous ce qui se passe au
lieu de prenne aujourd'hui vous
personnellement j'imagine que vous avez
des contacts en Ukraine qu'est-ce qui
peut se passer du côté de la population
est-ce qu'elle va se laisser faire même
si elle est dominée militairement est-ce
qu'on peut craindre le chaos si Kiev
tombe dans dans les heures dans les
jours qui viennent
je voulais juste revenir une petite
seconde sur ce qui a été dit les menaces
de du président Poutine il faut pas
oublier que l'accord sur l'anneau pour
l'opération des armes de moyenne portée
a été
abandonné du temps du président Trump
entre les États-Unis et donc du coup la
moyenne c'est Paris et c'est Berlin il
faut pas le négliger il faut pas
l'oublier et ça c'est une menace qui
grandit depuis plusieurs années
maintenant en ce qui concerne mes
contacts en Ukraine ils sont
il y a deux façons de réagir aujourd'hui
prendre des armes pour partir il y en a
qui ont décidé de partir prendre le
véhicule emmener leurs enfants en
Moldavie en Pologne pour pouvoir éviter
la guerre pour eux en tout cas et pour
la plupart des Ukrainiens ils prennent
les armes la loi martiale le permet de
se faire équiper quand on est en âge de
de se battre et donc la le patriotisme à
qui depuis 2014 depuis l'annexion de la
Crimée me fait dire que les Ukrainiens
se battront jusqu'au bout et que
l'acupuncture n'est peut-être pas
envisageable et donc dans ces conditions
ce sera une guerre totale et durable
guerre totale et durable bouquet de
parlementaire je sais que voilà c'est un
enjeu démocratique aussi qui se pose la
question le temps qui est quand même une
question
et durable j'ai toujours pensé va depuis
qu'on est rentré dans cette crise j'ai
toujours pensé que Poutine irait loin
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure qui remettrai
en cause le statu quo et lundi j'ai
pensé qu'il ne se satisfait pas de des
républiques de l'eston
mais là je pense quand même je peux me
tromper je suppose je me trompe un peu
comme Julien Sorel dans dans Stendhal où
il disait ou sadal dit qu'il se trompait
en supposant aux gens plus de sagesse
qu'il en avait mais j'espère ne pas je
crois quand même que le Vladimir Poutine
est conscient d'un double d'une double
limitation à son offensive qui est la
limitation périmétrique ne pas rentrer
dans le domaine de l'OTAN parce que là
c'est vraiment
Roumanie
extrême témérité et d'un
irresponsabilité totale de la part de
Poutine que de s'engager dans un conflit
direct avec les États-Unis ce qui serait
impliqué par le franchissement du
périmètre de l'OTAN et deuxièmement je
pense également qu'il a conscience du du
plafond technologique et du fait ce qui
est compliqué parce que la doctrine
nucléaire militaire a beaucoup changé
avec le cyber et cetera mais qui se
gardera quand même de recourir à l'arme
atomique on verra mais c'est vraiment
les deux les deux plafonds à ne pas
dépasser à ne pas crever c'est c'est
c'est c'est
sur le temps je voudrais quand même dire
une chose qui est importante pourquoi
nous avons accueilli un certain nombre
de pays dans le temps comme la Pologne
et cetera les pays baltes parce que ça
avait été des pays dominés dominer par
l'Union soviétique et qui aspirait à la
liberté qui avait besoin d'être protégé
pourquoi nous n'avons pas à accueilli
l'Ukraine parce que c'était un pays qui
s'était librement dissocier
dans un accord général sanctionné par
les accords de 94 garantissant de la
part de la Russie les frontières de ce
pays qui était un pays libre et ce que
fait Poutine et là où c'est quelque
chose c'est vraiment une transgression
importante c'est qui prend ce pays libre
et qu'il le réduit vous vous posez la
question de savoir à notre
interlocutrice
ukrainienne de savoir si il allait notre
collègue rien de savoir s'il allait
comment les populations allaient réagir
il les transforme en tchèque en polonais
hongrois c'est-à-dire en population
soumise vassaliser alors que Luc alors
qu'il prétend que l'Ukraine est un pays
frères unis par des liens fondamentaux à
la Russie et c'est là où il y a une
contradictionale chez lui qu'il finira
par payer pour terminer ce débat vous
allez tous les deux être présent mardi
lors
on en profite pour le dire
les heures qui viennent
excuse-moi de faire encore un petit coup
dans le rétro mais on a vraiment
l'impression Poutine poursuit un
calendrier très bien organisé la
première des la première des des menaces
la Géorgie ils y sont toujours depuis 10
ans avec la transit
pas ils sont les doigts
et puis après
la prochaine le prochain sur la liste
donc en fait
je pense que si les informations que
nous recevons je crois qu'elles sont
fiables je pense qu'il y en a pour 24
heures ou 48 heures
les milliers des dizaines centaines de
milliers de gens qui fuient ce qui va
aussi créer d'autres d'autres problèmes
gentillesse d'être patiente c'est
toujours plus compliqué à distance mais
votre témoignage et votre analyse de
parlementaire nous était très précieux
merci à vous et à demain
[Musique]